hi I'm Bill Hader uh I was able to stock
up I'm Andy B hi I'm James Branson what
the was that hi I'm Ken all fired I'm
Wyatt off I've chosen Jacobs
hey I'm Jessica Jesse and I'm Jay Ryan
hello my name is Jacqueline gryzor our
play Eddie in it
chapter one and it throws number two and
this is Jaden Martell and he plays a
bill and it took number two and this is
Jerry Lee Taylor he was Jeremy we're
here to take the which it character are
you quit test test
yeah Quizlet quiz test first
how would you your BFF is icon right
here then tough genuine funny sincere
determined brave it's a determined is it
good work yeah determined I would yeah I
would call why this chair I would I
would like to say oh you funny my sake
are you funny or just say it
let's see I said you sincere this is
here funny I'm gonna go with sincerity
simply an idiot yeah I'm gonna say the
determined hopefully hopefully genuine I
would say fine I'm genuine this is
sincere same thing obviously is
undecisive I'll go determined I go with
sincere how would you describe me
tougher genuine are you pre tough yeah
where would you hide from Pennywise a
bathroom a tree house a sewer a carnival
a basement in abandoned house I think
these are all four pairs right I'm gonna
call I will go with carnival - it's like
a big open space
Oh tree house really what do you gotta
go to a bathroom because I feel like I
can like just like lock myself in I
would do a carnival yeah there's a bunch
of you cuz I get it outside so how many
places that you're going to sewers one
way yeah I'm sure that's turnable get me
out of sewer and that's where he was at
every resides this basement that resides
definitely a treehouse 2d doesn't reside
this with ungood cute I would never hide
from tiny wives in any of those
locations because they're all scary I
wish there was a church I would probably
run to a church dallas myself an
abandoned house a basement
what crazy person runs to a basement to
hide from a killer clown that's what you
find penny wise in the basement I guess
a tree house because that's the most
open you have the more places to run
after my answer you have like you know a
viewing platform what are you afraid of
small spaces flying Heights wolves clown
spiders I hate spiders fools I would say
Heights I don't like spiders I'm harsh
go small spaces than Heights honestly
I'm doing small spaces oh yeah that's
their walls
pretty small spaces spiders both yep I'm
riddled with small spaces on this one
yeah austere [ __ ]
they should have snakes for just yes
makes is my number one I guess I'm more
afraid of spiders than I am of flying
though that's close but I'll say spiders
pick a Stephen King book Pet Sematary
misery 11/22/63 carry the stand shiny
the stand and be on the stand to read
shining
between misery and Kerry for me my
misery Carrie I love shiny Carrie I want
to say pets impact I'm gonna go with
this shiny I'm understand
mine is misery cuz it's misery Chastain
I'm there but I'm gonna go with the
stand because that's the extent one me
cheers a clown I like the will work for
laughs guys because that guys have cut
down was a lot kina I like the regular
guy that was looking and you know he
like this guy who doesn't really care
yeah he's not even real clown you know
something that's funny
yes the race the driving development
climate I'm thinking the one that looks
like it was made in the Soviet Union in
the late 50s so I'm looking at the guy
who's unemployed looking for lapses yeah
I want that
this in turn a guy that I feel like we
need you to but knows an ad on our
BuzzFeed intern I want to make the guy
who glasses in there a nice maybe one it
looks like the Flying Nun yeah I picked
the one with the mask who is it like -
looks like a lineup like the doll off
the top row absolutely not no one
because that's just creepy
what do you want to do with the clown
though choose a clown to do walk
probably the middle bottom one that's
she looks sweet she looks like a real
birthday surprise why at the bottom
right he looks like he wants nothing to
do with this quiz yeah I'm gonna go will
work for laughs because creepy clown I
like his sign these are that's my ladies
entrepreneur your monster
hey choose an 80s movie stand by me et
Ferris Muller Breakfast Club The Goonies
Ghostbusters I'm so Ferris Bueller these
are good
down it stand by me I don't say
Ghostbusters between the Goonies in
Paris Ghostbusters no Ferris Bueller's
Day Off et you take for me is like there
that's I would say the et - whoo
I'm gonna go with The Goonies Ferris
Bueller's Day Off stand by me Oh thick
I'm gonna go ugly with ET finally to
something important from it Georgie's
yellow raincoat Darrien the losers blood
of Eddie's Comcast the sewer or Ben's
poem for Beverly Fenn's poem for better
Hades arm cast so what is yours blood of
I'm gonna pick the entire city of the
entire town of Derry Eddy's farm cast to
the sewer you are the blood going yellow
raincoat obviously been Sloane for
Beverly because that's the only positive
thing on the split your fear hair is
winter fire January embers Ben's poem
I'm Mike Hanlon dude we both got Stanley
I'm Stan you're Bill Denver I got then I
got Richie Tozier I guess daily URIs who
is the character I always say that I
should be I got bill Denver I got bill
den Broeck
I go whoa I remember the first character
I ever auditioned for minami edition I
edition for Bill and I didn't get it is
this rigged that's right or is Ben
Hanscom the best character in it then
your personality matches Ritchie your
sarcastic optimistic and passionate like
Ritchie
you're the person your friends often
turn to when they need a good laugh you
don't tend to take life too seriously
and you March the beat of your own drum
you like long walks on the beach your
personality matches bill you're genuine
committed and loyal like Dale you're a
natural-born leader
who prefers to surround yourself with a
tight-knit group of friends you often
lead it's their part damn straight
you're in personality that is my your
grave pragmatic and sincere like like
you're someone who will charge headfirst
into danger your personality matches
then you're brave genuine and smart like
Ben you're sometimes underestimated by
those around you but you love to prove
those people wrong you have a close
group of friends that you consider your
failure
uh yeah well I think the costume of Ben
Henson was pretty pretty good well
precisely there's some competition maybe
I would have been a good bet he's the
sweetest
he's a sweetest your personality matches
Stanley you're meticulous all hearted
and hardworking like Stanley you're
cautious when it comes to stepping
outside of your comfort zone while
you're a creature of habit you trust
your friends to lead you down the
correct path
everybody we just did it none of us or
the characters that we played so clearly
we're a miscast
I thought I was gonna get there
I wanted to be been doing was occurring
Ben's architect he's good with numbers
hey guys I just click this out and it
has like those like live webcam things
for corn huh just who had this before me
[Music]